this is cinnamon yeah why does it smell
so not cinnamon
whoa
[Music]
hey what's up everyone my name is Tui
and welcome to a special edition of
making it big the show where my friends
challenged me to make their favorite
foods big if you notice that my table
here is a little warped that's because
we're filming everything in VR I know
really really cool if you want to watch
the full VR episode you can watch it
with a meta Quest 2 headset in mega
tasty that's our virtual cooking world
within Horizon worlds or on metaquest TV
today I have a special
spicy guess hello
you guys the flavor Force Queen is in my
kitchen thank you so much for blessing
me with your presents thank you for
having me happy holidays
I have a very special challenge for you
today I know you're probably expecting
something really spicy yeah but I'm
gonna lean sweet today oh I think it's
everyone's favorite dessert for the
holidays it is
cinnamon roll
you want me to make it big I do I want
you to make the world's biggest cinnamon
roll oh gosh the icing to dough ratio
needs to be on point okay so you know I
like my sauce icing is like sweet sauce
if I don't succeed I will just get you
one from the mall
foreign
consolation prize but I believe in you
thank you I will see you soon I'll see
you later all right good luck
wow
okay
let's make a big giant cinnamon roll
I'm gonna start off by making the dough
so I have all-purpose flour here
and I'm also using whole wheat flour
this is going to help with the structure
of the cinnamon roll I have my sugar
here oh and by the way this is only one
batch of the dough some salt Ginger and
yeast
this dry mix
[Music]
so this is 16
whole eggs there's actually 32 in the
recipe
a lot of butter in this recipe and hey
I'm not mad at it I love butter I just
feel like everything in life that's good
is bad for you and that's just not fair
I have my milk over here
molasses
so this is a holiday recipe and that's
why we're using molasses to give it that
you know extra holiday flavor
all right and I think it's time to add
the dry in
working with this much dough kind of
scares me because I just hope that it
rises
for next season can production get like
a commercial mixer or what are we just
gonna continue to do this by hand
[Music]
I think I'm ready to cut this out onto
the counter
here we go
so my dough is getting there but in the
meantime tiny toy is here to entertain
us with some facts so let's hear it
so it was the Egyptians and the Romans
that had the original sticky bun but it
was actually the Swedish and the German
immigrants that brought their version of
the sticky buns to America and it wasn't
until the 1950s where the cinnamon roll
as we know it the ones that I'm making
now was created and gained popularity
I think
we are ready to go in the bowl
[Music]
so while the dough is rising I'm going
to make the filling literally the best
part of the cinnamon roll so I have the
basics here the butter and the brown
sugar a lot of butter brown sugar here
and you can just like stop here but like
I want to make this special for Jing
because
I love Jing so I have all these spices
here for her spice it up
this is ginger salt and a bag cinnamon
five spice cloves I love that all these
spices are the spices to make fun but
we're making cinnamon rolls
imagine a fur cinnamon roll I don't know
if that sounds good but like it's a
possibility it shares the same
ingredients right
[Music]
there you go oh man what a big boy
I think it's time for another ASMR
listen
wow
I have my filling here
oh
um I'm just going to spread it
all over this dough besides eating the
cinnamon roll this has to be my favorite
part of making a cinnamon roll
[Music]
[Applause]
the moment that I've been not looking
forward to because this can make or
break my cinnamon roll
[Music]
so usually with the regular cinnamon
rolls at this point you just cut this
put it on the tray Let It Rise but we're
not making regular cinnamon rolls we're
making a big one so I'm gonna continue
to keep rolling
[Music]
oh
what I'm gonna do is cut this in half
and just kind of like patch it you know
I think it can only fit one more I want
to leave a little room for it to expand
[Music]
let's bake this bad boy
[Music]
again I have butter what's new
this recipe just has so much butter
cream cheese
and then I have my vanilla extract here
and my salt
powdered sugar I have some milk over
here that I'm going to just add in
slowly
got to taste test Katsu
oh my gosh hmm
that is so so delicious let's crush up
some cookies
I'm not angry I promise
foreign
[Music]
I've just I've never
gorgeous
this is my big giant cinnamon roll
[Music]
so proud this is it I'm really hoping to
get drinks approval and I think she's
here come on in Jing
hi oh my God okay are you ready I think
so yes okay three two
oh this is the giant cinnamon roll that
you asked for oh my God it looks exactly
like the cinnamon roll I gave you
earlier but giant are you ready I'm
ready my use of help are you okay
[Music]
oh
all right thank you
take two take two yay oh my God oh my
Lord here we go
here's your slice of cinnamon roll all
right cheers
[Music]
what I love is that it's not too dense
and you see how there's so many flaky
layers and with all the you know the
spices layered in between
that is exactly what I asked for and
what I was looking for so you did great
shall we take this home and finish it
let's do it all right let's go
you need help turn yeah
wow wow
I'll get the lights later okay
[Music]
[Music]